hey what's up my name's samuel leeds
welcome back to my channel
this is a property investment question
and answer session
where you can literally ask me any
question you want
about property investment finance
mortgages and i'll do my best to
answer from my experience to help you in
your property journey
so please right now below in the comment
box
start asking your questions and what i'm
going to do is i'm going to start
answering questions from last week and
while i'm answering questions from last
week
if you have an offshoot to a question or
you think oh that actually reminds me
about i'm stuck with this or i'm stuck
with that
anything at all comment below go crazy
and let's see what happens next week
when i answer your questions
also please give me a massive favor hit
the like button also if you're not
subscribed
imagine how awful it would be if i'm
answering your question
in next week's q a video and you don't
even know because you didn't get a
notification
to say that i'd uploaded a video so go
ahead subscribe turn the notification
bell on
and let's see what questions we had last
week so we have got
um john augustus who says
how do you decide what letting agent
is reasonable to work out your roi
god bless you thank you very much john
so
um in terms of roi working out your
return on investment and also
calculating that in with your letting
agent fees firstly
generally speaking a letting agent for a
single let property will typically
charge about 10
of the rent and that will be to manage
the property
to collect the rent um it'd be a
reasonably hands-off experience for you
the investor
some charge a little bit more maybe 12
if it's a hmo they might even charge
15 but 10 is
standard industry norm so when you're
working at your return on investment
you're very simply just going to work
out
how much profit are you making every
single month
which will be your rent minus your
management costs your maintenance and
voids and your mortgage payments
and then whatever profit you've got
you'll take that profit
the annual profit and you'll divide it
by your total investment
so in other words if your total
investment was 20 grand
and your annual profit is 10 grand then
you divide 10 grand by 20 grand which
will give you 50
which would be really good and typically
i look for property investments that
give me
a 20 or higher return on investment
and of course if you're using other
people's money then your return
your return on investment is infinite
because you've not invested
anything at all i hope that answers your
question thank you so much
all right kevin humphrey says i have a
property
with land to the side i have completely
restored
the three bed semi property i have
planning
passed for two two bed semis
that's awesome what is the best way to
raise
funds to complete the build great
question kevin
um so there's a few different ways you
could do this
if you have got planning to
build a house you could try and get a
bridging loan
um it would also depend on whether
you've got a charge already against your
property
so i'd probably suggest speaking to a
mortgage broker
or a bridging company you could raise
the money from a private investor
but before you do anything i would
suggest working out
is it worth building or not what are
your figures so
how much is it going to cost you to
build a second property
and what is the end value going to be so
i'd work out your figures
work out your due diligence and then
present that to
either private investors or to
bridge bridging companies development
finance
but if the deal's good and if the
figures stack nicely and there's profit
to be made
you should find that it's very easy to
get the finance in place if you need any
further help
or if you want to drop me a message on
instagram or on facebook kevin
please go ahead and do that and if
there's any way i can help personally i
will
sounds like you've got a really juicy
potential deal um lined up
hey by the way if you enjoyed the video
hit the like button that would really
help me out
okay george short says for my next
project i'm thinking of doing commercial
to residential in london
by taking advantage of permitted
development but i don't understand
how commercial property is valued
great question george commercial
property is actually one of the easiest
types of property to value because it's
valued based on
the rent so if you've got if you're
buying a commercial property whether
that be an
office block or whether that be shops or
hairdressing salon it's the property is
going to be valued
based on how much rent it's bringing in
that's why some properties or not even
properties you can have a tent
or a a steel warehouse
you know the steel the little tinny
steel
might be worth peanuts but the warehouse
which is made out of this steel is worth
a fortune
because the business is paying a lot of
rent
to be in that warehouse a hairdressing
salon will be
valued based on how much the
hairdressers are paying for the
premises now that's how it's valued okay
the really good thing about what you're
looking to do is if you're wanting to
turn
a commercial property into a residential
property
commercial property right now is falling
it's dropping
because more and more people are working
from home especially in london you're
right about the permitted development
and there's also more changes coming in
in august which is really really
exciting i can spend a long time
talking about that right now but i won't
um but commercial probably
in london there's a lot of offices that
are empty right now um
which means that the values of the
property is dropping significantly
so however residential property is
booming
so buying a commercial property using
permitted development to turn it into a
residential property
is actually a really really smart move
so again if you need any help with that
drop me a message if there's any way i
can help you or
deals that i can look at i'd be very
very happy to assist and help on that so
great job i hope to see you win all
right
ben mack says me and my partner are
wanting to get a loan
to invest in our rent to rent business
what type of loan is the best to do this
many thanks ben all right ben so first
thing i'll say is
if you're gonna get a loan to set up a
rent to rent business that's not a bad
move
i wouldn't say it's a good move or a bad
move it really just depends on
how successful your rent to rent
business ends up being i probably
wouldn't suggest getting a really big
loan
you don't need more than about five or
ten thousand pounds
max to start a rent to rent business
i mean a lot of people have started rent
to rent businesses from practically
nothing
in terms of where to get their money
from uh first thing i'll say is this
disclaimer it's a rent-to-rent business
comes with risks so if you're going to
be borrowing money
to put into doing rent-to-rent deals
make sure that you can afford to pay the
money back
should the business not be as fruitful
as you hoped
also make sure that when you're putting
the money into the rent to run business
you know what you're doing you
understand the business
you've done due diligence you understand
the supply the demand
the best case worst case you get the
business if you get the business
and you can afford to pay back the money
should it not work as you hoped
you could get a credit card you could
get a um
a business maybe not a business loan
because they'd probably say it's too
risky
um ironically they'd give you a per
they'd happily give you the money
to get married but they wouldn't give
you to do a rent to rent business which
is interesting
um an overdraft you could team up with
somebody you could find another investor
and you could say hey look
i'm doing a rent-to-rent business could
you put
three grand in i'll start the business
and we'll go 50 50 on the profits on the
deal there's loads of ways
there's an unlimited amount of money on
the planet they are printing
hundreds of billions you don't need need
one billion
you don't need one million you don't
need one hundred thousand you said
two or three grand so good luck keep me
posted on how you get on ben
jesse let's say you're 19 with a couple
thousand pounds
what strategy would you start off in
property i would probably start with
rent to rent if you've got a couple
thousand pounds
rent a studio apartment
and get permission to then re-rent it
out
on airbnb and booking.com pay 700 pounds
a month
but then rent it out for 150 pounds a
night
of that of those bookings pay the rent
pay the bills and the management and
then the profit
keep for yourself on average if it's
done right
each property that you do like that
should make you a minimum of 500 pounds
per month
with 2 000 pounds if you play your cards
right and you know what you're doing you
should be able to turn that 2 000 pounds
into 500 pounds a month it's not going
to be passive it will involve a bit of
work
but you've only got to do that three or
four times and you can replace an
average salary it's very very doable
i've done this i was going to say
hundreds of times and then i was trying
to work out i have it hundreds of times
but i've done this countless amount of
times and so many many of my students
all right samuel haptu how can i learn
about property investment
without spending 500 pounds for a crash
course
i'm broke so is there any way i can get
started without money
all right samuel um firstly the crash
course is not 500 pounds the crash
course is one pound
okay most of my training is either free
or
ridiculously affordable so
the very fact that you're kind of coming
about this with this mindset of
like it feels to me samuel like you've
got a good name
but you're coming about this with i'm
broke i haven't got this going for me
isn't it hard i would say to flip the
cards
okay there's three there's three
currencies that exist
there's money which you don't have much
of you don't need
lots of money to come on the cross
course bro you need a pound right
there's money
but there's also time and knowledge if
you haven't got money what have you got
focus on what you've got going for you
rather than what you haven't got
um and and and is it possible of course
it's possible to make money
starting with no money but you will need
time
creativity and a can do attitude so
focus on that first and then maybe
different things will start happening
need any help give me a shout hope to
see you win all right last
question aaron ashworth i have equity
of 350 000 pounds in my house
and a buy to let but probably can't
refinance my home mortgage as it is
approximately five times my income
if i switch my home mortgage to interest
only
i may be able to release 150 000 pounds
to start training and buying some more
property
is putting my home mortgage onto
interest only a good idea what are
the risks um
is it a good idea i would probably say
yes i mean listen i don't know your
situation
and i can't say yes go and do that it's
your decision
you're an adult um but personally i
think that a
interest only mortgage is probably
smarter than a repayment mortgage
and the reason being is because number
one you're going to pull out some equity
which is great
because your home that you live in isn't
paying you any money
it's not getting you rich it's just a
home that you own paying off the
mortgage quickly isn't going to help you
it's just going to
reduce your expenses slightly you don't
need to reduce your expenses slightly
you need to become financially free to
build a portfolio
so that you can live the life of your
dreams so i would probably say
if you do it right refinancing
pulling out 150 000 pounds then being on
an interest-only mortgage
leaving your debt on your existing home
but then using your equity to buy more
properties
to then rent out and then with the rent
if you do it right you can pay
off your mortgage interest payments but
there'll be a big difference which you
can live on and enjoy the cash flow
that would probably be a lot smarter
so that's my two pennies i hope that
helps
thank you so much for watching the video
but let me tell you something i want to
answer more questions
i'm excited for some juicy questions so
comment your questions below
i will try my best to respond to as many
as i can in next week's q a sunday at 7
00 pm
be there or be square make sure you
subscribe over here
if you want to see more information
about our training programs you can
check out a trailer right here
go watch that it's not 500 pounds it's a
pound
and i look forward to seeing you guys
next time thanks so much
peace out